I want to make a
quick correction
to the video on quasars.
In that video I said,
and I mistakenly
said that the creation
disk that's really
releasing the energy
of the quasar,
that it's releasing
energy predominately
in the x-ray part of the
electromagnetic spectrum.
And that was incorrect.
Most quasars are
actually emitting
electromagnetic radiation
across the spectrum, all the way
from x-rays, as high frequency
as x-rays, all the way down
to infrared.
And some quasars even release
super high frequency gamma
rays, and they'll release low
frequency electromagnetic waves
all the way down to radio waves.
So I just wanted to
make that correction.
It's not predominately in the
x-ray part of the spectrum.
It's across the spectrum
right over here.
It's this entire
range of the spectrum,
and sometimes even
a wider range.
Now, the other thing
I want to clarify
is this is the range of the
spectrum that's being emitted.
But we have to
remember that most,
or actually all of these
quasars are quite far away.
The closest is 780
million light years away.
Many of them are many, many
billions of light years away.
And so they're moving away
from us at a very fast speed,
or they're getting redshifted
because the universe is
expanding so fast relative
to us at that point,
or that coordinate is moving so
fast away from our coordinate.
And so even though this is the
spectrum that's being emitted,
it's all going to be redshifted.
It's all going to
be redshifted down,
and so we are going
to observe things
at a much lower frequency,
maybe around the radio
part of the frequency.
So everything will
be redshifted down.
And that's why these
were originally
called quasi stellar
radio sources.
Anyway, hopefully that clears
things up a little bit.